this is Startalk this is Startalk cosmic
queries edition I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I've got with me as
always my co-host as not as always as
sometimes as always ha ha and sometimes
always I'm always sometimes Eugene
Mirman and this topic today is science
literacy and I've got with me a YouTube
star who is a science educator herself
Vanessa Hill Vanessa welcome thank you
yeah lively debate up and down under
apparently you would go for a few years
like I'm not so fresh but I know I do I
found fresh yeah you sound Lizzie I'd
like to keep it that way really know
what else I would we love ourselves
emojis here in the United States so up
welcome you've got a YouTube channel we
are here in YouTube studios I did is the
connection it's called brain crush brain
crush
very nice very much like that PBS
Digital Studios at the PBS digital image
a very nice to hear that yeah doing lots
of cool educational content and it's
just youtube.com forward slash
braincraft go watch okay alright and and
so this this set of questions yeah be
solicited our on science literacy so
we'll get to compare our notes yeah
being kind of in the business right
alright so using what you have Adam
Fazio from facebook asks in the
information overload era how do we
determine what to pay attention to how
do we convince others to pay attention
to impartial data based information when
it's not as sexy or scary as the
mainstream media or advertising which is
carefully engineered to play to our
psychology I wish I had just a short and
concise and really good answer for this
but it's so complicated that sounds
completely like a question you should
answer well I think you at ages violent
on on YouTube clickbait and sexy
thumbnails and things like that plain to
this so much we're with PBS like how can
we get our PBS information overrule
alter the BuzzFeed's of the world right
it's really really difficult and it's a
I think a fine line between education
and entertainment to try and get that
information out to pay you tamen yes and
possibly in my work we have to say the
word you can just do it yeah well yeah
okay yeah yeah you know what's your
answer
yeah I guess the way that we do it is
just I mean as YouTube show who's just
through sexy visuals in a way like we
have lots of cool animation we'd like to
try and draw and now we do do this every
week I do we have a lot of how do you
have it in you every week I'm a shell of
a human man Oh Jimmy the words
information overload because I'm like I
can't fit a single thing into my brain
okay for but I I mean it's interesting
though because there is so much
information out there and sometimes the
credible news sources aren't the sexiest
news sources so I think I think it's
hard I don't think there's a perfect
answer for it I think we can possibly
just try to share credible news and
right there fake news that we keep
hearing so much about yeah and sometimes
it's hard to spot so I think we need to
think critically we need to be
discerning and we I think we need to be
open to information sources that maybe
aren't just like little pieces of candy
right yeah longer yeah more of like good
beef or chicken yeah less candy more
chicken something substantial yeah yeah
so I have two reactions to that question
one of them is the older you are the
more likely you are to say the following
sentence yeah I suffer from information
overload are you gonna say back in my
day yeah yeah so so what I found is
older people cannot keep pace with the
level of information that's coming out
right the emergent whereas younger
people whether or not they can or can't
keep pace they don't feel overloaded by
it I don't know anyone 20 and under who
walks out of it walks away for the
computers I'm overloaded by the
information this is not their state of
mind right it is a playground there's an
information playground to them and they
embrace every
bit of it I remember before the Google
search engine there was a big joke that
went around the internet is great
it's a great library except all the
books are scattered on the floor and you
didn't know how to make sense of google
searching so now that's not a joke
anymore it's a it's alright so now we
can search it but now you can search
something that's not true and find
everyone else in the world who believes
that not true thing right there by
affirming your not true idea making you
think that it's mainstream that's one of
the problems of the search engines right
so they ought to be a way to rank the
integrity of information in a search so
that you can then choose do I want high
integrity information or low integrity
information and maybe some days you want
low integrity information and just have
fun there it's got to be a playground of
cockamamie ideas so I would love to
learn a bunch of lies and then apply
them to my life but really I think it's
right now the educational system doesn't
have as any part of it
internet intelligence so you think that
the educational system should prepare us
correct you appreciate you going to be
discerning so that when it is time to
learn what is true you put in your truth
filter and then you know how to interact
with all of this information to build a
tree filter into the car into the
curriculum that is yes that's definitely
going to happen
okay all right all right Thank You Jean
thanks for thanks for being my co-host
thank you very much for our talk and of
course we had this woman here but that's
a hill guys you got our own YouTube
channel nobody ever gave me a YouTube
channel she got old you can you put your
mind to it ya know what it is yeah put
my mind to the folder like every single
day oh yeah so so braincraft right now
at a channel near you know you can
search very easily just put braincraft
into google enter this little bunch it
will pop up you'll see my face hawaii
comes up in a google search because
Google owns YouTube you get it probably
come up being a third a third would not
recommend don't bang it bang it big if
you've never allowed
because we are in the YouTube studios is
that even villa anyway AltaVista the
number one remember all the research age
90 afternoon km the show police know
what I meant $20 you've been watching
possibly even only listening to star
talk
I've been your host Neil deGrasse Tyson
thanks again to Vanessa and of course to
Eugene for helping making this show what
it was as always I bid you to keep
looking up this is Startalk